congresswoman Omar returned home to
Minnesota to a different kind of chant
as you heard their supporter shouted
welcome home Ilhan yesterday she was
back in Minneapolis for a Town Hall Dean
Reynolds was there and joins us from
Minneapolis Dean how have people in that
area responded to this controversy well
good morning Omar has a lot of
supporters here in her hometown as you
might expect they turned out in force
last night both at the Minneapolis
Airport and at a town hall later on and
those we spoke to blame the president
for picking a fight with the
congresswoman a fight they described as
disrespectful and dangerous
[Applause]
congresswoman Omar told supporters at
the Minneapolis Airport she is not
backing down there was more applause for
her later at a town hall where she kept
the discussion on policy not politics a
lot of people that are trying to
distract us now but I want you all to
know that we are not going to let down
many in the town halls audience the
president's racist tweets and rabble
rousing rhetoric in North Carolina
Wednesday night were deplorable I think
most children are really uncomfortable
with this behavior and probably realize
there's something wrong with the adults
and there was a feeling here that the
president was intentionally
misrepresenting what the congresswoman
has said about her adopted country with
the idea that patriotism is something
you have to love
or else get out of it I think she loves
the country but she wants it to be
better than it is right now and when one
of her supporters told her never to back
down from a bully congresswoman Omar
said quote oh he's met his match Anthony
redeemed thank you